today we're talking with the one and
only Stephen he who you probably know
from these two words emotional damage
even though you might recognize him from
his wildly popular comedy skits and TV
series behind the scenes he's an
incredibly shrewd businessman
entrepreneur and comedian who's about to
share his secrets of success money and
the realities of living in China if you
do not pass this exam we're talking
about 13 year olds 14 year olds here you
were basically like Shackled to a life
of labor on this episode of subscribe if
you haven't done that already although
before we go into that we gotta thank
our sponsor now thank you very much
Graham for that wonderful intro before
we get on to that I'm sure a lot of you
guys are college students that want to
build your credit but you're either
scared you're going to overspend or
you're like Dave Ramsey and don't want
to take on any debt and if that's the
case then today's sponsor Fizz might
just be the perfect solution for you
this is the debit card that builds your
credit and earns cash back with this you
get a credit limit based on how much you
have in your bank account and they offer
an auto paid feature so that your bill
is paid off automatically every single
day and of course if you're like us you
might be wondering but Grant and Jack
how does Fizz make money well fizz's
Revenue comes entirely off of The
Interchange fees that Merchants pay so
it doesn't come from the card holders
and the best part is that you don't need
a credit check security deposit or
cosigner to sign up this also reports to
all three major credit bureaus building
your credit score like a normal credit
card would without having to worry about
building up some insurmountable debt so
sign up for Fizz today and get your card
instantly on Apple pay well your
beautiful first edition Fizz card gets
shipped to you directly Fizz Partners
directly with MasterCard and Lead Bank
and also International students can
apply without a Social Security number
so sign up using our link down below and
start building your credit in a safe and
accessible way again the link is down
below in the description and now with
that said let's get to the podcast how
many Waters do you need Jack ah just two
this guy's actually incredible he will
go an entire podcast without a beverage
which to me is just maniacal to be
completely honest because I don't
understand how you can talk for that
long without needing oh you're right but
yes your mouth gets so like dry that's
right when you talk yeah yeah he doesn't
want to spend money on the water
Consultants
we should totally talk about cheap this
because I take pride in the house
we have a conversation topic that's
great all right let's let's see who's
cheaper you know his personality is
actually real like a lot of people are
surprised to hang out with him he's not
joking he's actually that
it's incredible I think it's reasonable
I bet it is no I believe you because I I
think it's something to be proud of you
know I am as well did you grow up in a
household that was cheap or like like
conservative financially very much by
the way are we rolling yeah okay great
oh wow nice I like that just go right in
without an intro that's awesome
um I grew up in China and and the
mindset was very different like I didn't
know anything about investing at all I
didn't understand like Financial
intelligence or inflation or anything
like that like I remember growing up my
um my concept of money was
I make money and I save it like if you
were if you were a smart person we're
asking for you saved it
um The Not So purpose of make money and
spends it and they they get in trouble
for not having money
um and so uh the the saving kind of
mentality was really a part of my
childhood like my upbringing
um but that's the culture as well I feel
like in a lot of Asian countries is just
to save yes always the same yeah yeah
really oh yeah that's the for well did
you not know this no okay so I have a
very biased perspective stereotyping or
anything that is not what I want to be
doing here okay but in college I was at
UCSB now the people that drove the
Porsches the people that drove the
Pharaohs people that drove the Mustangs
the people that were the Louis Vuitton I
noticed where the foreign exchange do
yes usually from the Asian countries and
I always like kind of figuring like okay
what's like the trend here you know
because I can't be oblivious to
something like that like do they don't
have money oh I can give them I can give
insight to that um so yes during that
time like the recent maybe 20 years and
my lifetime is very much within this
China had a massive massive boom like
China went from I'd say my grandparents
uh
you you know there was not an abundance
like like people were hungry a lot from
my experience not I can't speak for the
whole country but just my family's
experience
um and then my parents generation were
born and when they hit adulthood that's
when like China exploded all of a sudden
everything was made in China so so these
businesses
um sort of popping up and as you can
imagine like anything in manufacturing
you know Logistics where we would make
the stuff that you see in like Walmart
um that put a lot of wealth in China and
all of a sudden uh people who weren't
used to having wealth would gain wealth
very very fast like become millionaires
in a year or so by opening up a factory
or you know the entrepreneurs who would
take advantage of that massive boom and
then this is funny in my generation when
I was born which funny I was born in the
in the one child policy so um I didn't
know a single person like a classmate
with a sibling not one like maybe what
would happen happen if you ended up
having a second kid I don't know because
you can't just stop that mind my
understanding is that isn't their
attacks so it costs money or I think
I don't know if we could talk about that
does the baby go bye-bye I believe I
believe so if it's
female I think the males were
this right here I've heard the exact
same thing now I don't know if this is
true or not but this is just like a lot
of Americans perception of what happens
I'm sure a lot of viewers can relate
maybe a lot can't but like a lot of
people think that like the the women
babies less desirable because yeah they
like go up for adoption or something
like that the less desirable yes I have
heard of that um well the answer is I
actually don't know I never I was never
told the actual rules okay
um but yeah you could only have one
child and there was this pressure
that your whole family's lineage kind of
rested on your shoulders and so you can
imagine right the the pressure this is
this is where the whole you must get an
A you know all that all that uh culture
of uh being extremely tough on your
children kind of comes from
um is that you don't have anyone else
interesting to carry on the lineage and
that plus the the big pressure in China
at the time of the economy and what kind
of careers we had access to
Opportunities yes the opportunities
um it was a much like tougher
competition than it is here
um that's just from some personal
experiences when I was 13 years old we
were about to do this thing called
tonkal and that is where it's like the
deciding point of if people continue on
education or don't and my experience
growing up was it was largely accepted
that if you do not pass this exam uh and
and get into a school because if you
didn't get into a school that was the
end you went out you got a job you
didn't continue education we're talking
about 13 year olds 14 year olds here wow
um okay uh that the impression that
everyone around was kind of having was
if you didn't continue you were
basically like Shackled to a life of
Labor to being a delivery person forever
or a farmer
um you know you would have a bad life
basically we were told that our parents
would beat it into us the school the
society would beat that into us that you
have to pass this exam
um and uh the the passing rate was not
high from what I know from my city back
home it was less than a half
less than a half get to continue on
education where you would have a hope of
a a good career you know like a good
income where you could raise a family
and things like that
um that was my experience growing up I I
don't know about other parts of China
but I'm from Shenzhen
um and so you can imagine the massive
like
stress and pressure
that Society puts on and the family puts
on to a child which they're definitely
children 13 year old is definitely a
child
um and and yeah that was the concept
that like I I never learned or
understood
Financial intelligence in the way of
like investing in how to make money work
for you
um it was just rather simple of you get
money you save it because you likely you
know you're not going to be able to get
money in the future or or things will
happen that will cost money
um a lot of Concepts were stranger to me
but I was coming to the west and am I I
think responsibility this might be my
individual experience because I am
particularly uh uneducated in this field
like I it took a while for me to
understand medical insurance and why the
hell people have it Canadians feel the
same way yeah don't worry it's not just
you yeah yeah so like in China you you
get sick you go to the hospital you get
what you need and that's it that was the
end and you paid like I know the price
of a pizza for a regular visit so it was
never anything you consider
um it's all subsidized by the government
though
oh I don't know because there's no way
you can pay the price of a pizza for
some actual the government really owns
everything though so of course they're
going to provide Health Care to their
citizens citizens make a lot of uh
business they're very productive the
government wants to help those people
survive and keep working
I fully admit I am very uneducated in
politics in China
um but yeah the reason I brought up like
kind of the field was
um one of those long tangent
um people like that's what people in my
parents generation got wealthy
um when no one was being no one's used
to being wealthy in China and as a
result they kind of gave their children
everything that they didn't have and I
knew many like children who was either
my classmate or close to me friends who
were like this and that's where you see
the Louis Vuitton wearing kids outside
because we kind of go growing up anyway
now might be different but growing up we
considered coming to the west to mostly
England America Canada you know these
countries uh is considered like the best
place to send your kids for a good
career and a good life
um and when those very rich Chinese
people send them over they just give
them everything they want so that that
represents a very small number of
children and we actually have a name for
them we call them or die which
translates to Rich second generation so
that that is exactly what you were
describing earlier and I I know I've
seen many of them myself I was not one
of them unfortunately
yeah I had quite a few Japanese and
Korean friends uh they were very much
like their families were very much don't
show don't no flash very modest save and
be it like very frugal and like that was
really important yes it was uh wow
that's that's fun to think about back
then like growing up in China there's a
lot of experiences I would love to share
with you guys like please please do I'm
sorry curious oh oh like going to school
everything was cash by the way I was
kids everything was cash I I barely I
didn't really know about bank accounts
like my parents probably had them they
probably had uh before me it was Cash
like you would get your allowance and uh
I'd probably get like a hundred Yen
every week living through such a happy
man what's the conversion what would
that be like a few dollars American I
believe I yeah probably
less than ten dollars maybe okay
um and what you could buy with it yeah
that's
pretty good pretty good
a 10 allowance a week
twenty dollars what is it forty a month
was two dollars a week
of inflation
a better reference is probably what it
could buy rather than you know the
dollar exchange like what I could buy I
remember
um oh man I'm so happy even thinking
about this on the way to school every
morning it was like seven a.m and I was
the monitor so I had to get the extra
early to take care of all the all the
responsibilities
um I would stop by like a rice noodle
stall and these were all hole in the
walls literally like they didn't even
have a have a front wall there's a
building with a with a room cut out of
it uh let alone not having a door they
didn't have a wall
um and it would generally be like one
person running the whole stall you know
making rice rolls and uh and uh serving
people making Financial transactions and
cash which now I think is probably not
very sanitary
and I remember a rice roll would cost
like five Yuan uh going to school in the
morning and I would maybe get like an
extra soy milk or an extra Shalom ball
and that was that was everything and I
particularly remember as well the the
people that I saw were very happy like I
remember this one guy who ran a rice
roll stall he would he would need the
dough and make the food and he would
dance to it every day so I'd go get my
food and I'd watch him like like working
away dancing and I always like remember
that because I like to think he he was
that was his dream you know I think
that's the thing he probably came from
somewhere much worse and he's just so
happy to have his own stall and to have
his own business and to be able to feed
kids on their way to school and you know
what before we go into that though I've
seen a lot of people try to get into
businesses and I've seen firsthand just
how difficult getting funding could be
which is why our sponsor fund and grow
wants to help that's because fund and
grow understands the challenges small
businesses go through when they try to
get the funding that they need
traditional bank loans come with tons of
restrictions in the slow corporate
bureaucracy that's right Graham however
fund and girl offers a simple and unique
alternative with a 12-month membership
you can secure you're up to 250 thousand
dollars of credit at zero percent
interest without giving up any equity in
your company fundinger also has over
four thousand four point nine star
reviews because their streamlined
funding process delivers fast and
efficient results that has already
helped out tons of small businesses and
as a special offer funding girls
offering a business funding program
showing you the five steps to obtaining
up to 250 000 in business credit and
also as an exclusive bonus you can enjoy
up to a 500 discount on their services
so take action now and begin growing
your business visit fund and grow today
down below in the description and now
with that said let's get back to the
podcast uh yeah and then like bubble tea
swept over I remember this Summer that
all of a sudden everyone went from
drinking Coca-Cola to bubble tea and it
was it multiplied like more than
Starbucks's today just took over the
whole the whole city
um I remember that and so yeah it was
the cash and the things that we would
kind of flex or be happy about was oh
look I got the new snack I got the new
spicy peanuts yeah yeah that was awesome
there would always be stalls outside the
school in like a a car that could be
wheeled away in a second yeah and they
would sell the strangest things now that
I've come to the West I I've realized
that a lot of the things they were doing
were taken from the West like there was
this year in school it must have wow it
must have been like 11 or 12. yeah 11 or
12.
um where all of a sudden hash browns
became the thing now like like the
McDonald's hash browns like they come in
the thing exactly hash browns they have
a McDonald's the exact shape good yes
and I I wonder where do they get them
because I gotta later on I realized they
were the McDonald's hash browns is this
a it's like an off-brand or someone
figure out how to buy it or just go
through the supplier that McDonald's
goes to like those are the stuff like
growing up what I remember wow uh off
friends was huge oh my God I love this
topic I genuinely love this topic oh my
gosh I've made a lot of videos uh skits
about offline products you know that's
like my childhood growing up so every
chip bag I brought was our friend every
like give us an example like do we have
Doritos and then you're like what's yes
the product would be sometimes pretty
close sometimes way off like you'd go to
you go to a stall
um and these would be like Shacks you
know the part of a building uh products
just laid upon like like a wooden board
with with Ledges so sure it put bags of
stuff on the wooden board uh and I used
I remember I drank stuff I drank uh this
lemonade drink that was that I thought
was Sprite I didn't even know what
Sprite was but it tastes did completely
off but we're like oh well this is what
you drink you know we grew up here is
what's available
um we had our friend versions definitely
of potato chips lots of potato chips
Pringles Pringles would be an easy one
yeah so many yeah uh rest oh my God
don't give me some recipes
which ones restaurants I swear where I
grew up this was
um there must have been like five our
friend KFCs
they would copy the exact items care of
themselves like KFC will come out with a
rap they would come out with a wrap and
they were like five times cheaper I have
no idea how they managed to swing that
kind of Rises uh that was KFC not in
China it was it wasn't China
was there no like legal issue between oh
bro I bet good luck trying to shut that
yeah I bet at this moment they were
shops with my face just plastered on the
front and I don't know anything about it
oh my God yes I bet I bet I bet I bet
yeah yeah you shot one down and five
more to open up like the next day
quick it's a real thing like for no
reason you just see someone's someone's
a pineapple you stole was like Tom
Cruise play slapped on it going like
this I swear you see that everywhere you
go it's probably still happening today
so I love that stuff the off-brand uh
but now Jack brought up a question
though legally can they ever I mean I
know they're not they they maybe can't
shut them down so what's the strategy is
it just to open up and like just do as
much business as possible I I think it
was such a common thing that people took
it for granted like I don't think KFC
ever went oh let's close them down I I
doubt that well being an American
company I see they would probably want
to do that but culturally no one went
around going like that's not supposed to
be here we kind of just enjoyed it this
is the part of it all
um but copyright does have a a bit of a
different um oh my God but like how
exact were they in their copying like
KFC do people know oh that's KFC but
like he's similar to Canada was very
very similar they copied they copied the
art words they would draw exactly the
same but they might swap out like
instead of a what do you call that thing
it's a bow tie or it's a regular tie
um little bits they were probably I
Remember products that were so similar
to the real one it'd really take you a
second to see oh there was an extra dot
on the the wording or you know oh this
one has an extra line at the bottom
could it be named Kentucky Fried Chicken
like KFC I bet there was like most of
the time I would see them switch up one
word or one syllable here but I I'm
quite confident there are a few that
straight up pretends to be like not even
hiding just straight up saying we are
KFC when they're absolutely not
that exam when you were 13. I was
wondering that I didn't do it I actually
immigrated before yes right before
literally right before I immigrated from
Shenzhen to Ireland and I became an
Irish person through immigration and
China so if you immigrate as a Chinese
person you do have to forfeit your
Chinese citizenship
um so uh so that's what happened I came
over and I joined the Irish system uh
and that was a whole other world it was
you know throwing myself into a very
different social structure with
different language different manners all
of a sudden everything I knew was uh it
was different so I was very much thrown
on the deep end and what were some of
the differences between the two Oh I
thought of two things let me say these
two things before we continue oh my God
it's gonna be so funny this is like this
is like a stand-up bit you know
everything we talked about is great uh
there's two two off-brand things that I
remember uh specifically
um growing up that when I came to the
West I was like oh my God this is how
things worked first one was movies oh
this is this is terrible because I am in
the film industry this is terrible this
is what it was like growing up
to watch a movie you went down your
building out to a stall that would that
had essentially a cupboard box with like
200 DVDs inside it and they were all
rip-offs none of them were licensed or
anything they all have like uh these
were didn't have boxes they were like a
envelope printed with the movie poster
you would take out and you'd be like oh
this is this movie and you pay like
something ridiculous like too good like
nothing sense for it and you brought it
home and usually it was a different film
because it wasn't what it was yeah I had
to rip you off buy one in New York I
thought it was Harry Potter yeah put it
on and it was a video recording of so
like some other movie someone was in the
movie theater
all the time yes yes and you would hear
something like coughing in the back yeah
in fact you would feel lucky if you
didn't get that yeah if I bought like a
film put it on and it wasn't a secret
like yeah it would have been a special
moment for me we saw like someone's head
in front of the thing like blocking up
part of the bottom of the screen uh same
with video games oh my God you would buy
a video games and and plug it into a
computer it would be a completely
different video game and that's the
another big I want to share this
experience because it's going to be so
fun to you guys
um growing up there was this game
everyone played it was like the Oh you
talked about it in school you know is
the popular thing
um it was a racing game uh like uh like
Need for Speed like that kind of result
but in a cartoonish style um not
realistic Mario Kart uh dude let me tell
you okay we um so it would be hype you
like practice on the weekends to get
better and all that uh and you'd pay for
the new skins the best cars it was the
cool thing everyone did it and then I
remember I came to the west and and I
kind of stopped playing that and I live
in the west a while for you know a
couple of years and then occasionally
one person just brought up this game hey
hey let's play Mario Kart I was like
okay they flipped on the game and I went
they copied the game I used to play when
I was back in China no I legit thought
Mario Kart copied the off-rand game that
we used to play and it took me like a
month to convince me no Mario Kart is
the original wow that is such a funny
experience you grew up thinking that's
the thing and you see this wait wait the
controls are the same you can drift too
wait what you can get items that you
could use on people they have it no but
it was the other the other way around
gosh so oh that's the story I wanted to
tell it's so funny gosh
sounds crazy how so how are some of the
Customs different than when you moved
out from China Ireland uh I I got a very
hard kind of experience because my mom
put me into an Irish school right off
it's literally the day I've told the
story before the day we landed in the
airport in the morning at 8am
um we went to this new home that had
never been and my mother had married an
Irishman and uh and she's like this is
your new father I was like wow you know
everything's so disorienting 8 A.M we
landed 11 A.M I was in school and my mom
said here's the principal here's Stephen
good luck goodbye how was your English
or Irish like a word what what language
they speak there uh in Ireland English
they speak English
don't laugh
girl you look more Irish than me you
probably have
a guy I've been trying to leave this
kind of funny Jack was asking what I
thought his IQ was before this that's
not an IQ question that's a trivial
Knowledge Questions
with IQ I agree I agree that is Trivial
knowledge Graham that's so funny that is
completely detached okay I'm just
uncultured that's simply what it is I've
never left the country
yeah this guy locked me in Vegas and
myself and I can't leave
when we have to shoot a podcast I go
right back into the cell right
afterwards dude that is so funny that is
exposed
okay they speak English in Ireland but
you didn't know him I thought Irish was
a language oh it is it is a language
okay all right oh it is a language yes
it's a language it's called Gaelic uh
that only about I remember the message
we went to Limerick my mom kind of moved
the whole move myself uh to Limerick
and I remember in the school there was
one other Asian person and he was
Filipino So within miles there was no
one who spoke Mandarin and I didn't
speak a word of English uh so it was
sink or swim uh my days were miserable
the only way I could cope was to copy
people like if I saw people sat down at
the chair I would sit down in the chair
but if they took out a red book I would
take out of my red book but I had no
idea what anything meant how do they put
you in class wouldn't they test you in
and realize like you don't speak that
well they know I don't speak so why
would they point you in there not make
sense how do you sit and listen it kind
of is like that I sit there and I just
wondered to myself what's going on today
expect you to sit through class on that
I don't know what they expect I guess
they just but you couldn't have possibly
learned anything no absolutely not
absolutely not I I guess um the first
time I moved to Ireland I was eight uh
so a little bit earlier I went back in
like chunks China Ireland China Ireland
um so the first time eight-year-old me
probably was more malleable is that is
that the word to use I I picked up
language faster so first year jeez I I
could not I could not understand
anything anyone would say to me
um and I developed like a a defense or
coping mechanism well where I would just
play dumb
um like if someone if the teacher is
speaking to me dude what else am I gonna
do I'm just gonna stare at you not
understanding the single word you said
uh when people brought me places I would
just go with them and uh and I remember
they they put me in the special needs
class as well with other mentally
challenged children probably because
they thought I was mentally challenged
for for good reasons yes I did very much
behave very dumb uh that was like the
first year and then just through living
I started to pick up uh what words meant
like occasionally I'd know what food
meant or what big large activities went
meant what riding a bike meant
um and then by two years I was able to
communicate like kind of normally I
would I would be able to communicate but
with many holes like
this is so embarrassing I wouldn't no
one would teach me this stuff because no
one spoke Mandarin so
um I would say things to a group of
Irish kids like hey can I read your bike
and everyone would laugh at me and I'd
be like what's what's so funny I feel
it's right not read I was like oh okay
yeah it was a it was a lot of that
experience hundreds and hundreds of
times
and that's kind of what developed the
defense mechanism to play stupid when
you first went there you had no idea
like how to speak English were you
effectively just mute did you just not
say things or did you like yeah I didn't
you just kind of sat there yes I just
sat there how would you do tests and I
pass anything no I wouldn't pass
anything the only thing I I had this is
kind of funny actually the only thing I
understood was numbers
so to the Irish kids here is a guy that
is completely silent that doesn't
understand anything but he would like no
master than the teacher and so they
thought it was kind of stuff so I'm
gonna cut some fun you know but in
reality I just didn't speak the language
and my math was very Advanced and so I
would uh I I would know quite often
actually
um math topics better than the teacher
does so that created a funny little
perspective that to other kids might
have been entertaining
the teacher wouldn't call on you though
because they knew like they learned I'm
sure after time Stephen because he would
kind of speak back yes that is true yeah
they did call on me and end out of what
I always fail because I would stand up
and I was like I don't know and I just
sit back down would you ever just speak
Mandarin though like just like
explaining something uh it didn't make
sense to me to speak Mentor really yeah
uh yeah I didn't I I suppose it was such
a uh social like subconscious hit that I
developed up the shell and I developed
Like A coping mechanism
to to dissociate in a way and that I
believe that kind of made me really
introverted as you can imagine and so I
spent the vast majority of my childhood
even my uni days in my room I would play
video games I would not go see a single
person and I feel that about Ireland
that I I'm a little uh sad that I missed
out on that whole experience I've never
went to a single party I never went to
the bar which all the kids as soon as
they're 18 they went to
um I had like one friend who would
occasionally accomplish FIFA with me and
that was it and even in my uni days I
spent the whole time in my room it was
only after that when I went to like
acting training that I began to open up
in terms of personality and actually be
able to talk to people and share a
connection tell stories like learn how
to interact so yeah that was quite the
experience I'm glad I'm the way I am now
it's it's very I I enjoy company you
know I enjoy talking to people I enjoy
hearing their stories now and it's much
better than like playing video games in
my room yeah when did you come to the
U.S about five years ago I came here
because of an acting school called the
neighborhood Playhouse so I wanted to
become an actor when I was 13. and now
being like after understanding a lot
more I understand the reason I kind of
started was because I I needed
validation because I felt lesser I felt
really lesser like everyone else had you
know what they had and and their pick
their parents came and picked them up
from school when I had to walk home
alone kids other kids could have that I
couldn't you know there was there was
many situations where like I'd be I'd be
in a living situation where another kid
would for dinner for example would get
the fresh bowl of rice I get the
leftover bowl of rice it's just a lot of
experiences in distilled that lesser
feeling in me and because I felt lesser
than people I craved you know for people
that tell me I'm important and I deserve
to be here and so for that result
unconsciously
um that's why I wanted to become an
actor and now now that I know that I
have much more power over that I was
like oh I don't kind of create
validation as much as the child version
of me did and so it's because of that I
did a lot of theater uh I went to London
to do a bachelor's degree in acting and
then I was 20 years old when I graduated
my bachelor's degree I went to New York
to the neighborhood Playhouse which to
my knowledge is one of the best acting
schools on the planet with many
oscar-winning alumni who are actors as
well so that's why I came and then I
finished the acting school it really
changed me as a person because a lot of
the a lot of the defenses I built up I
wasn't aware of before but through that
process I learned more about myself
about what made me the way I am and
that's actually the reason I I can
change myself now because I understand
oh so I feel this way because of an
experience lives inside me from when I
was 12. and that has helped big time so
then went into the industry uh did a did
a bunch of stuff I was in like Comedy
Central I was Showtime I did a bunch of
movies where they weren't huge like not
many people sold them but I was the lead
and stuff but that was not a career
that's a whole other Story how did you
how did you even get into that like
Comedy Central like some of these things
are pretty big how did that what did
that it was just an audition process at
the time uh I did a lot of theater I did
61 stage shows and I haven't done one
since it's been a while 61 stage show
since I was 13 years old in sunjun in
Limerick in London Edinburgh and uh New
Jersey and New York so I've done a good
amount of theaters through like my
journey that I've built up and then I
entered the film industry and at first
it was waking up every morning
submitting to 20 acting jobs and I was
really hungry I had drive like crazy so
I would uh actively lose money to beg
for a job I was like I I will fly to
Illinois to do a Shakespeare play at my
own expense flight and lodging and they
probably play nothing anyway I was that
hungry I just wanted a career but I was
also very uh I was unaware of how kind
of difficult it was to have a career in
acting like I didn't know the stats or
rather I might have known the stats but
I was I was emotionally disassociating
myself from it I was delusional thinking
I'm the one in a million you know I'm
gonna be the lucky guy how were you
doing all this when you didn't know
English oh no I knew well it took me two
years yeah at this point I'm nine years
old Oh I thought you said from 13 to
whatever age you would yes oh from 13 to
17 I did a bunch of theater and then
1701 and 13 new English fairly fluently
yes I do okay because I started when I
was eight yeah so I could speak well
maybe with a strong accent yeah probably
with a strong accent
and then 17 went to train uh 20 years
old train again 22 graduated went into
full time and the way you I got into
these
um roles was to wake up submit to 20
jobs and out of those 20 like maybe a
week I'd probably do three three
auditions five auditions and a lot of
them were by myself in my room so I'd
set up the camera I'd perform I'd send
in the tape or going into the room
so I I was in New York at the time I
traveled to the place the whole
experience every actor is familiar with
this
um and uh occasionally I would land my
Landing rate is very very very low
very Hollow like what dude what's the
ratio so I have applied to uh about 3
100 jobs and it wasn't just me it was
also I had an agent who would apply on
my behalf as well so with the two of us
together we we'd apply to like every
chance and I was hungry enough to not
care about money at all
um
out of the 2010 3100 applications I
landed I'd say seven
when you look at Stats so I I I I will
specify as well Landing a job
is barely anywhere close to a career
because like I was uncommon essential
for one day and uh
how should I like okay of the seven jobs
I landed and if I was like flexing my
acting achievement they would be pretty
strong you know people would go oh you
were in comedy Central's aquafina's
nowhere from Queens they'll be ah cool
good for you but I have never made a
month's rent
so as an actor you're expected not to
make enough money to to live
um and there's many stats to back me up
like after actors I remember it's about
96 or 97 of Stack after actors that is
the professional Union here in America
um 96 97 need another job because their
acting cannot they cannot live on their
acting so having a career is like rare
extremely rare to just earn a 40K 50k a
year and then being the one in a million
obviously that is a lot a lot rarer yeah
right that's right so how are you
supporting yourself through that time oh
that was my mom and dad that was all
about Mom and Dad supporting actors says
oh they made a joke what was that the
Oscars uh yeah and it's The Stereotype
like my mom and dad supported me big
time and it was because of them I had
the time to end the energy to go at it
as hard as I did so if they did didn't
support me I would have to like wait
tables which actually did to a short
period of time but I'm really fortunate
in the in that rent was covered my
mother and father paid for that
um and most of living was covered
yeah for like two years and we did have
some we did have some hard like
conversations there
um because of the reality of it you know
I was right I began really starry-eyed
and really delusional
um and uh I remember like this was the
moment that changed everything for me
and it's kind of when I started to go
into content creation as a strategy it
wasn't a passion it wasn't it was me
trying to use a new media's platform as
a strategy to leverage against
traditional where do you find the
inspiration for a lot a lot of your
videos a lot of the comedy what's the
what's the process like there is a real
wow that's a great point because there
is a struggle there
um
the struggle is this this question of
are you an artist or are you a
professional and for my whole career up
until now I've chosen the professional
and the difference between an artist and
a professional to me is an artist
expresses a professional delivers
the difference is the direction an
artist makes what they want to make a
professional makes what the audience
want to see and I've always taken that
route and that's lead to a lot of
burnout I'll give you this the clearest
example
um I came up with the Asian Dad
character maybe 200 and some videos in
and uh and it was a hit it was a massive
hit and I was like oh dude this is so
exciting bro I have so many ideas
because I grew up with this like a joke
about that I had like 20 ideas and then
I made all 20. and I've ran out of ideas
you could just repeat the ideas though
like that's where you go back to idea
one and then you just add a few
sprinkles in there I had to so I had to
do that I had to do version twos of
things that I'd already done I had to
repeat jokes that I I maybe add a little
bit but it was the same joke you know
how many times can you joke about
getting B in math I've done it maybe
five six times now seven times yeah but
you could do a minus oh my God it's so
bad hey why no a plus I guess this goes
back to a little bit of the a little bit
of the experience thing the audience
experience I would hate to see my
favorite YouTuber do the same thing over
and over again I'll get bored in three
four times
um and so I care about that for my
audience I always try to bring fresh out
into content and never
uh redeliver the same value if I do make
the same thing again I try to add all
brand new value in there
um so I made 20 I ran out of ideas I was
like but it's not about what I want to
make it's about what they want to see
and the viewership was very very very
obvious Asian Dev video 10 million views
agent video 10 million views skit about
my acting career 100K agent video 10
million views so it's very very clear
what the audience wanted to see so I I
sucked it up I
forced myself to come up with the ideas
anyway I made another 20 and I was burnt
out but I made another 20. I was burnt
out but I made another 20. and now we're
like 80 skits into this character now
um and uh yeah it's still that question
do I make content I want to make or do I
make content people want to see I make
content people want to see great that's
been my Approach when you say exactly
that I look at what are people watching
right now on YouTube what are the
trending topics and I'm going to talk
about that okay because at the end of
the day I make content for other other
people and of course like I like to
interject my own little jokes my own
thoughts into it because that's where I
have fun but at the end of the day it's
like I'm doing it for the audience and
so I'll talk about whatever people want
to hear about that's great so like I
admire that and like that discipline
like for me side hustle and passive
income videos are my least favorite I
can't stand making these videos but but
they consistently do well yeah like over
the course of a year they're my most
viewed videos by like two to three times
but I just can't stand making them and a
lot of it's repeated yeah but people for
whatever reason I don't want to watch
the video you made a year ago on I want
to see the new video today even though
the same info I see that because you
know I I've seen the same sort of skits
that you've done and I'm like I don't
want to watch the old one I want to
watch the new one because you grow as
you're on you know your audience is
going to grow they're never going to
look back at the old videos they only
get recommended what's in the last like
few weeks okay that's very fast so yeah
so anyway it is that perspective and I
guess the best kind of advice I've heard
about this this
topic is from my friend Ian and he
mentions the way kind of he does it is
he'll make two for the audience and one
for himself
um and I feel like that could
really help in terms of creative burnout
because a government like the the
writing is the hardest part if I get
scripts every day I can make 100 videos
you know a month that's easy shooting is
easy performing it's easy coming up with
the jokes is hard and in the way I work
as well it is more complicated because
one of my advantages that that took me
past my peers is how fast I deliver
value and how often I deliver value
um my content is comedy skits that is my
my main content and of course the value
that I deliver is comedy laughs
basically
where key and peel would deliver two
laughs in three minutes I would deliver
30. and that was my advantage
in becoming Stephen he an outgrowing all
of those channels that I studied before
um so if I have an idea it's not really
worth anything because an idea Asian dad
goes to grocery store I still have to
write 30 jokes and that's where I have
difficulty oh we've already joked about
the rice five times yeah have you
thought about hiring a writer yeah I
have tried Jesus Christ I have never
found a person who uh who who can
do it in the way
this channel has been doing right okay
yeah so very difficult walk us through
your creative process you come up with
the video Asian dad goes to a grocery
store yeah how do you like what's the
first step okay like what is like an
Asian something
that's pretty easy uh I write jokes so
uh I find that we'll take the idea store
um I sit down on my computer and I write
about 30 jokes uh which oftentimes was
writing like 50 and deleting 20.
um so I would write hey what's funny uh
the fish oh there's always fish at Asian
stores let's make a joke about sea world
hey you always wanted to go to seawolte
there you go you know that's good yeah
wow like that's a joke and then I go on
and write another joke another joke and
then after I write all of the jokes I
curate them in like you string it
together to create some yes and then
yeah and there's actually a massive
skill in the curating as well because
it's not about narrative at all it's not
about narratively screwing them together
first we go to this section that we can
actually the curation is actually about
the experience
um so this is where I've developed very
Advanced kind of ways
um to optimize for
making the experience good
so it's not random it's not like I'm
doing a Banger Banger Banger mediocre
joke video joke no I'm actually curating
them in a way that's essentially like a
DJ I'm not giving all the Beat Drops up
front like maybe all the Beat Drops
behind
um I want the experience to be a way
that I want which is also a a tactic for
the algorithm as well you can call it a
retention tactic uh yeah and then I put
the jokes in the order that I want them
by selection of value what value is it a
big laugh is it a small laugh is it a
chuckle and then once I have the list of
30 jokes I use narrative to string them
into a coherent uh script and I put in
the characters I need to put in I I
write the dialogue and uh that's the
script done how long would that take you
to do
I have fun I have on a hack recently
usually that take me ah it doesn't be
like
15 minutes or three days because I I'd
often
uh try to force jokes out of my head and
I have a really hard time like no matter
how hard I squeeze I'm staring at the
paper and I just can't think of a joke
or other times like the emotional damage
video took me 15 minutes to ride I was
like oh that's a Bitcoin wouldn't that
be cool there we go and it's done yeah
yeah walk us through that video that
video oh okay all right ah this is gonna
get all the views let's go this is why
we're here the emotional damage video is
called when Asian is a difficulty mode
um initially I had I I was playing at
Dark Souls that was I was playing Dark
Souls and uh and I loved how the
characters died you know what it's
called ragdoll physics right when you
get hit the character kind of like Falls
as if they have no bones
I was like dude that's funny I want to
imitate that in real life I wonder how
how that'll look
um and so I was like okay so let's write
a skit where
um let's try to skit where
the character would like die 20 times
and and for for the sake of you know
delivering the audience what they want
let's put Asian Dad in there
um and I the the difficulty mode I came
up with was what if like being Asian was
a difficulty mode because it's really
damn hard you know a lot of things are
particularly hard about our culture not
that we're harder than anyone else but
being called you're fat every day by
your mom is emotionally damaging and and
moments like that
um and so I went on to okay so we need
like 20 deaths all right let's try
something that's funny that a character
can die from a character can die from
being hit by a leaf falling from a tree
write that down a character can die from
stepping on a stone write that down and
one of them was what else can a
character die from before besides
physical damage oh I know someone roasts
them and he dies of emotional damage
write that down and I wrote like I don't
know how you gotta count on the video
and many didn't even make it so probably
20 deaths
throwing that together how am I going to
compare Asian dance fear obviously he's
not the character that dies because it's
a video game let's put him as the
reactionary character he's the one
playing uh so the main footage happens
in game but each death I'm gonna add the
punchline by cutting to his reaction
shot he plays the game character in-game
dies uh on screen we put the death
emotional damage or whatever and we cut
back to him he is mad he is screaming at
this game because he's so annoyed and
one of them was emotional damage so
that's how that video came about you
have to say it
emotion no damage
oh my God views for days let's go I'm
tired of saying that
no it's about the experience of my fans
that's lovely it brings so much joy yeah
oh my gosh I've been waiting for you to
say this
is that one of your like most highly
requested things during fan encounters
he's like hey can you say it oh not that
much actually nothing really sometimes
people will ask that but mostly it's for
a selfie or mostly I like this about my
fans because I I've really put a lot of
effort into building a connection with
them they actually have conversations
with me like I appreciate that more than
anything because I've seen the other
side I've seen when a celebrity is
viewed as a product and then every
interaction was hey can I get a selfie
can I get a selfie you get a selfie
thanks bye
um and you know when you're looked at as
a product it doesn't feel so great but
thanks to you know the the connection
that we have every conversation is
intimate they come up they go oh my God
Stephen you have to make this video
again because my friend I was just
talking about this and this blah blah
blah that's a real human connection I
love that I feel like if people looked
at me like a product like they do a
regular a-lister then ah it would I
would be starved of human have you
thought about doing Asian Dad doing
cheap life hacks like Extreme
Cheapskates sort of thing like that
would be hilarious oh like obviously
like garbage bags like trash bags I love
what you mentioned you know one of my
fish bags is trash common yeah it's
common a lot of cultures garbage bags I
didn't know this I did that all the time
and then people reached about grocery
bags sorry
grocery bags
yeah grocery bags and trash bags I did
that in a CNBC video and everyone is
commenting a little like he does it like
my culture does that too I didn't know
that's how common that is yes one of the
first grocery bags yeah one of the first
uh Asian cultural skills I've ever made
was this uh this parody shopping channel
where an Asian mother advertises used
plastic containers as if it was like
Gucci it was like come get your used
Olive Garden container that can contain
three lunges for your child and it's
just like a used
or a tub of um cheese pots but you
finished the cheese well so it's just
it's like the the grandma thing where
you have the tin of biscuits but instead
of biscuits is knitting things
yeah that's exactly that so that's a
great idea I've done a lot of skits
about the being cheap that that's of
course one of the biggest laughing
points I've written hundreds of jokes
about that
um and also the off brand I love I still
to this day love making off friend
related skits Grant has some great
things that you could take away for some
skits you're making yourself oh it was
great he reuses the same flosser right
there's Dino floss he reuses them
wow
pants
take it out take it out why get a
close-up because look that thing is it's
hanging on for dear life to be honest
it's clean look at why is it all free
don't touch it I'm not at least he's
sanatorium
I always keep like one on me I love her
I love that thing how many times do you
use that today yeah
like after the Chipotle okay yeah but
let me let me add a cheap life hack of
my own because I like she did this like
two days ago when you go to oh my God
you're gonna hate this
this is what I sometimes do uh you ask
for a large ice latte right and then you
you get the latte first you wait till
you get the latte and then you say oh
can I have a cup of milk I do the same
thing and they just give you the thing
yeah yeah you could ask cream on the
side they just give it you mix it and
you have two lattes effective it will be
even better you get a regular black
coffee okay they give it to you and then
you say oh by the way can I get a cup of
ice yes pour it over yeah the ice and
they say oh can I get like a little
thing of cream or whatever you might
need or so you get three cups basically
no the little cream is like a little
thing oh it's in a little container see
that's crazy because you're basically
getting 300 the amount exactly yeah
exactly the ice takes up oh yeah when
they pour the ice in that yeah you're
really only getting half a drink the
other half's water so just get the
normal coffee pour it over ice which is
free uh there is a tick tock too that
I've seen but Ford that tells you how to
get all the same Starbucks drinks for
cheap by ordering them like differently
wow yeah like there's a way to order a
macchiato by like getting one thing and
something on the side you know what I
did with Alex here's the thing we went
to a sushi restaurant okay and I noticed
the um Philadelphia roll was fifteen
dollars but you could get a salmon roll
for nine and I looked at that I'm like
wait a second so they're charging six
dollars just to put cream cheese on the
on the inside of the Roll that doesn't
make any sense yeah so I said to Alex I
wonder if I could just get cream cheese
on the side
and I asked can I get a salmon roll and
just get cream cheese on the side I'm
like how much is the cream cheese I
think I was like I've never been asked
that before yeah like a dollar and I'm
like okay cool a dollar so he brings the
cream cheese and brings the roll so I'm
in ten dollars and I just take the cream
cheese and I put it on the top of the
Roll oh it's the same thing it's the
exact same thing I said five dollars I
never even see you ordering Philadelphia
rolls I like the Philadelphia yes this
one yeah I do like the cream cheese this
one made sense because it was a filling
roll I didn't want to spend the twenty
dollars like a fancy one it was like get
the I wanted that like for ten dollars
so I thought that was a good deal yeah
but they don't but they're not doing the
math on that like someone should really
it's a they should they should have
charged twelve dollars yeah not 15. yeah
but wouldn't the restaurant like try to
get whatever they can you know they'll
they'll up yeah he said it was the first
time he'd been asked that so I guess
somebody's thinking about it yeah I said
a cue Jack yeah and your IQ goes over
150 something starts thinking start
thinking away you saw that uh thing
though right because there's a huge
Chipotle exploit where you go in and you
get a taco and you basically load up the
taco with everything they have there so
you get like the rice the beans the
veggies the meat in there and everything
and then you ask for a side of tortilla
which is like 50 cents and you just pile
the entire Taco into the burrito
tortilla and you overload the taco you
can get double beans double rice double
everything oh you can get double chicken
and it turns out to be like three bucks
are you talking about you're getting one
taco one taco yes yes and you get double
because double rice is free double beans
is free double lettuce is free double
cheese is free double all that's free
they patch it there's no way I don't
know if I don't know if they patched it
but I think like they still do it but
it's highly discouraged for people to go
there because like I think because of
this girl she posted this Tick Tock it
got like 20 million views on super virus
and then there was this huge controversy
because everybody started going to
Chipotle using this exploit and they
haven't detached it because I don't know
how they would I don't know I don't
think you can't get those besides yeah
it would have to be at their discretion
to say no you fit that's too much yeah
but that you go in and get you know
three dollar burritos or whatever it was
and wow yeah so I tried a life hack
recently uh Panda Express apparently
used to if you show up 15 minutes before
closing give you discounted food or you
would be able to get like multiple meals
for the price of one because otherwise
they throw it out yeah yeah so I went to
a few Panda Expresses one of them
offered I think it was like 15 or 20 off
on the meal as just a courtesy sort of
like we don't really do this but if you
want to uh the other one the lady uh
ended up watching the channel and she
sent me a message afterwards on Twitter
saying hey I couldn't really explain
this in the store but we used to do this
and it we ended up having issues because
people would show up right at closing
and we'd have to cook food right before
closing a lot of it would go to waste or
a lot of employees would purposely like
cook up X extra food just to be able to
take it home so they stopped that but
they used to do it interesting oh yeah
because I do know about the waste thing
at the end of the day yeah they throw
the food away yeah bakeries as well like
yeah terrible bakeries are incredible
there's this Bakery in my hometown all
the high schoolers knew about it you can
go in and ask for the day-old Donuts it
was just like drive-through donut
restaurant and you you go in and they
give you like a box of like 16 donuts
whatever they have it's like a mixture
of donuts in a bag Donuts in a box it's
just like this huge like it's like the
leftovers exactly it's like this donut
Kona Cornucopia they just smart yeah and
you go and you give them and you're like
how much today and they're like uh four
bucks like you know
exactly out of nowhere and you go and
get like 16 donuts it's crazy it's a
great deal yeah it's amazing I love it I
would love to see more restaurants and
places doing that of the food that
they're gonna throw away anyway I
thought but I have heard like prep for
example when it was London uh they used
to
fresh make all the sandwiches in the
morning and at the end of the day they
would give anything left to a homeless
shelter that's awesome yeah yeah
completely free everything that's great
so they never have leftover essentially
thanks for the high-end restaurants feel
like it devalues their food because I
remember who was it that we had on
Joshua Weissman said that he was all you
wouldn't believe the amount of waste in
today's restaurants I saw that short
I've actually seen this short yeah
because I mean if you're cutting like
some crazy Baseball State cut right like
all the trimmings that go around that
they just get tossed and this is on like
super nice meat too they just yeah it's
just a cost of doing business no nothing
no oh sometimes
side dishes but a lot of the times the
food just goes to waste yeah all the
trimmings yeah that's crazy okay let's
go back to Comedy because I have a
question sure sure what do you think
about the current climate of Comedy
people kind of trying to tiptoe around
certain jokes and everything because I
noticed you you very much lean into like
the whole Asian stereotype and
everything do you ever feel like you
could be like
talking about something that's like
really sensitive or I don't know like
being insensitive towards Asian
stereotypes which well it's uh people
are cautious about it's intention
intention is the most important thing
what are you trying to do are you trying
to uh lightly satirize in a in a
friendly way in a loving way and to
share your culture with the rest of the
world or do you have negative intentions
that is the answer to your question it's
intention
um
because I come from China I I don't have
the upbringing of an American where I've
noticed and I respect this because I
know a consumer place of protecting
yourselves and hurt
I have seen the the Asian accent
I have seen the Asian accent being kind
of villainized by experiences of
bullying of racism of people who would
use the way we are against us
who would do that the kind of um racist
making fun of Asians in a negative way
and as a result I see in the United
States this obviously is not in China
but in the United States
that is where the negative rep for our
accent comes from but it would be an
absolute shame to let the bullies take
that from us it would be an absolute
shame the real laws here would be if we
are convinced that we are lesser because
of the way we are no no no
we should wear ourselves wear our
culture proudly we should it's totally
fine to be who they are to speak the way
we speak don't let the bullies take that
from us
if you're Asian were proudly because
damn I love being Asian
so intention it's intention what if
let's just say hypothetically right
there's a guy he goes he understands
Asian culture he's super excited he
thinks like oh these are funny
juxtapositions this like Asian
stereotype to this like white American
stereotype or whatever but he's white
and he goes and he makes a joke what do
you think about that oh then now because
his intention what if his intention is
good right like he just thinks it's a
funny thing and maybe he'll take bashes
on one side and Ashes on this side yeah
now we're talking about different
cultural moments now
um I am very new in the United States
and I'm not fully educated on the
culture here but I can tell you this if
that white guy went to China and told
that same joke to Chinese people from
China with fully positive intent and
it's an actual funny joke
I'd love it
but I'm not gonna comment on American
culture because that I'm not fully
educated in
I know Americans can be very sensitive
there was this like YouTube short that
was scrolling I deleted Tick Tock I'm
not a tick tock anymore but of course I
kind of migrated to YouTube shorts I
gotta shut that down spending way too
much time on it there's this YouTube
short and it was this guy yeah and he
was walking around to it was like a
University campus and he was wearing
like uh like a Asian or Chinese like you
know like the Hat yes I've actually seen
the exact videos
I'll show you the video and he goes
around these people he's like a just a
normal looking white guy but he's what
do you call like a kimono or something
oh uh well the female version is called
a tip Hall I don't know what the male
version is called but he's wearing the
the rice the traditional yeah the rice
farmer hat yeah you could call it a
recipe is that right yes
people do wear it to farm right that's
what I thought okay okay yeah okay so
he's going around to University campuses
and he's like he's all do you find this
offensive to American students none of
which are Chinese and they're all like
uh are you Asian and he's all no and
they're like yeah I would say so because
you don't understand their culture you
don't understand what they've been
through that's highly offensive that
you'd be wearing their clothes when
you're white and he does this and then
he goes to Chinatown where like he's
speaking to people that hardly know
English like very Chinese people you
know like they probably migrated here in
the past like 15 20 years and he's all
do you find this offensive and they're
like no I love it this is great we love
to see that you're you know experiencing
our culture you're trying to immerse
with us and uh yeah
um
one thing I would hate to do here is to
throw a negative view on anything
because I as with my limited view of
American culture
I must respect those who are who come
from a good place uh and and I there are
many people not Asian people who may
like do that who may say oh you can't do
that out of a place of love and respect
and that is I I very very much
appreciate that
um
yeah whereas uh how we think versus how
they think it may be different like if I
don't know if you know about this in
China
Chinese people love white people who can
speak Mandarin as well as we can oh we
met up with um Jama yes oh yeah New York
they're like we went there we went to
Chinatown yeah and we got people yeah
yeah and I'm like Joe do the things and
he orders it and you just see her face
yeah she lit up so happy it's the same
reaction in person as you see in his
videos yeah because I was like No
cameras were on the camera is a great
moment it was a highlight of my trip to
see her face light up I think it was was
it Mandarin yeah yeah and then on top of
that she was like I thought I knew you
because she recognized oh no way yeah
that's even better yeah it was awesome
yeah yeah it was so cool but it was it
sounded amazing it was like a beautiful
language and he was just like just going
back and forth with her it's just like
oh man yeah of course we love them we
love that and then this is the opposite
perspective it's true as well I I came
here and
um out of absolute love and respect I
assimilated to the United States I even
changed my accent to speak the way I do
now and I think if one comes from a
place of respect and love and absolutely
no negativity I don't think there's
anything wrong with myself
that's what I think I think I'm similar
to you in that it's like although I'm a
pretty insensitive person I don't take
offense to many things personally
whatever things I subscribe to religions
or you know based on my physical
appearance and stuff like that I'm
generally not very sensitive okay but I
respect the people that are sensitive to
those things because I'm a firm believer
it's all about intention and not outcome
and if their intent is to protect
certain people that's totally fine do I
think it's an effective solution to it
maybe not but I respect their intention
there indeed India yeah yeah I think
sometimes like to be completely fair and
honest if you're like defending certain
people that you're not a part of
whatever like you're also kind of in a
sense like agreeing that there is an
issue there in the first place you're
kind of validating The Stereotype that
I'm very new to that I haven't seen that
in any other Nation before yeah not it's
like you can't make fun of this certain
group of people yeah yeah because like
when you make fun of them like the the
strikes or whatever the cuts they dig
deep and it's like okay well you're kind
of only the person here that's assigning
validity to the statement this is
clearly an exaggeration of a stereotype
that's where the comedy comes in it's
not like you're just saying something is
blatantly the way that it is and that's
funny no you have to exaggerate a stereo
yeah you know that is uniquely to the
United States like um there are there
are a few occasions of that coming from
the heart in other countries like the UK
like Ireland where I was
um but I do see uh I do like for example
people who comment on my videos calling
me racist
I don't quite understand that
that is a difference races towards who
exactly towards myself I don't make any
sense what no so uh yeah it might be as
you described they have kind of Taken
something that could be originally good
intent into
something that is a bit overboard but uh
but then again I must admit I don't know
much about American culture to
um form a valuable opinion especially I
don't know enough about
the the experience of an Asian American
because um I I you know I respect
everything they went through and now I I
might even immigrate and become Asian
American myself
um even though the way we are with some
PC culture the way we are here now it
could have come from a place of heart it
could have come from a place
um of protecting themselves and and for
that reason I I don't know enough to
comment at the moment I just respect
their experiences and I'll learn more
about it what's the oddest thing that
you find about American culture that you
think is weird oh wow on the large scale
and on the small scale let me think
well okay so all the small individual
things like like American Health
Insurance okay that's pretty obvious
that's fair yeah uh
how
how much meat people leave off of
chicken bones
how a chicken wing bones that bothers me
that bothers me yeah well I take offense
to that you know what's funny
I'm that person I leave a lot of music
no way that is very uncharacteristic
exactly it's not though because I get
weirded out anytime a meat's on the
phone it looks too much like the animal
and I get weirded out by that so I will
eat only like the if I see like a vein
or anything going through that I can't
eat it oh he doesn't like eating stuff
that is connected to Bones yeah yeah or
it is okay veins tissue fat I can't skin
I can't eat it yeah it's got to be the
pure meat itself removed from the bone
sauce
yeah there's probably some word for
people like that because that has to be
some sort of a common thing right scared
of eating meat attached to Bones I'm not
scared of it I get weirded out I I do
relate in some cases I do relate I I
like I remember one I remember once um I
was eating crab and it was the whole
crab oh yeah and you had to break the
legs off that's a little I I could deal
with that believe me I did feel a bit
weird enough so I do I do understand you
yeah
um soft shell crab is kind of freaky if
you've ever had oh you know what I got
that last night and I went to all you
can eat sushi yeah they brought it for
free and so I couldn't not eat it and
how was that dude I have uh it was um
it weirded me out because you could see
the the pincher at the front yeah and it
was like the arm yeah the pincher yeah
uh and I was just like
um I don't like the idea of it I don't
like it but I ate it it tasted good yeah
but it's a little too crunchy and it's
the idea it feels like the animal yeah
for me it's sad because you're like
eating the entire being you know what I
mean whereas other things like that well
sure but when I eat like a piece of
salmon agiri I'm like wow this is you
know two percent of a salmon so I'm
probably fine you know what I mean but
like this is like the entire existence
of this animal is in my mouth you know
what I mean oh it seems like the it's
it's a very fleeting yeah thing like
that it's just gone after a couple bites
growing up in the in the local home that
we used to be at
um where my grandma and grandpa were
farmers
um not in the modern sense with all the
machines like they were they were you
know hoeing things in the in the yard
and as kids we often went visited a
grandma grandpa and we played with the
chickens that ran around and then we ate
it for dinner no
yeah that's true that's true yeah how is
that for you man was that sad is it
harder for you to connect with animals
because you'd like play with them and
then eat them
I know that sounds awful yeah dude
that's what we do we eat animals it's
strange putting in it but but we don't
play with them I feel like that I I have
a connection and a bond yeah and I don't
want like if I if I play with an animal
I can't it's an interesting I don't want
to know it yeah uh you do you do like
disassoci a little bit after food
security and things like that but you
know if we went back to days where you
had to hunt to eat uh then I suppose you
would connect more with the act of
hunting or the act of farming and
raising animals
um so yeah like for example I bet my
next Generation if I have kids and they
grew up in like this environment where
they don't have to kill a chicken they
would probably be squeamish as well so
yes I think it's a matter of um
the the security of the food if you need
to do that if it is normalized by your
culture
um things like that yeah so that's
totally cool it's totally cool for for
everyone wow
well going back to you how is your
business broken down now uh wow this is
such a great question
my my business now is mainly YouTube uh
the videos the comedy skits we make are
like the the front running IP they're
the most important thing I have other
channels that make reactionary content
uh where I repurpose things into short
form content
um they aren't huge they aren't they're
not huge especially the reaction to
content that's actually currently losing
money and we do have to put in a lot of
research into all right so what's the
what's the point of it if it's losing
money
it serves to build that connection for
those who want it and that's very
important to me you know okay
um and also I do want to make it a
profitable uh event or a profitable side
of the business so I will invest time
and a lot of research like this week
um I'm doing the research I'm asking
people who are who are specialists in
the the realm of algorithm and making
videos
um how I can optimize in order to get
enough views to not lose money
um so I am making making that uh that
advancement there but the bigger picture
is I I have a
like a journey that I want to take on of
making cinematic content fully
profitable in-house so I have been a
part of the traditional industry like
film and TV for for a while and I I kind
of understand how things work
um I have pitch shows to Executives and
that's the part I didn't like you know
you're at the mercy of a couple of
people
um and they get to decide what gets made
what doesn't
and so I took that like I'm tired of
begging for a job I'm tired of begging
to make what I want to make
let's see if I can do it myself so
essentially becoming the studio that
funds it and becoming the distributor
that monetizes it obviously our YouTube
videos every every uh YouTube has a
career we already do this with our
videos
but there are very few who can do it in
the form of cinematic filmmaking
you know when we when we look at this
business model we think of Mr Beast and
all of that and that's because of all
their tactics work extremely well in
competing for the algorithm so if I
bring on cinematic filmmaking I'm at a
massive disadvantage
um I do not have access to those tactics
and devices that they use so how do I
innovate how do I create something that
can compete so that my piece of
cinematic filmmaking content
can get your eyes as opposed to a Mr
Beast video or as opposed to a cat video
or one of those
so that's the Innovation we've had two
tries so far the first try is a big
collaboration back in April in the the
collaboration was a large part of it of
what tactics can I use to
um to elevate this beyond my regular
videos I invited a lot of my friends who
are huge creators in the in the Asian
community of YouTube together we shot
three comedy sketches in one day which
is amazing the set was run incredibly
well and it was a traditional production
we did employ 15 people we did put a
budget into the this is my personal
budget
we ended up being quite successful we
took a unique achievement of holding
trending six seven and one
simultaneously in the United States till
this day I believe I'm the only one
who's ever done that three spots in top
10 trending including number one did you
release them all like right at the same
time yes I gave one video to oh I I gave
um the set to my friends as well so that
the three comedy skits would be on three
different channels launching at the same
time and we basically sent our viewers
to each other's channels uh financially
it worked out it really did work out and
that's what showed me okay so I can
employ 15 people
um use cinematic
equipment like Cinema cameras Cinema
lenses and do things that look good you
know have a lighting team have all that
and be able to make profit if I innovate
on the retention tactics on the things
that matter in the algorithm and a bunch
of other tactics that is surrounding it
as well like outside you know like um
using our uh using a promotional
strategy that is very rare like when you
think of YouTuber videos we don't really
promote our videos and most will share a
story about it but when nine of the
biggest in the community come together
and make peripheral content that kind of
let people know when we're coming
together we're doing this this massive
thing it's amazing
um then that Drew more people to the
thing and so the next attempt is
currently still ongoing is a show called
ginormal
Jonah will play on the word ginormous
yeah and it is a parody of a 1970s
Japanese kaiju show Kaiju show being
Godzilla Power Rangers big monsters
fighting big Mecca and we're a parody of
it so we're making fun of how how bad
those are back here basically uh and
this we are innovating again with a lot
of new tactics and going much much
bigger now it is a six episode actual
scripted narrative series
um with nine amazing creators who are
who are great friends of mine and who
happen to be more professional than most
actors I've ever worked with so I got
really lucky there
um and now the challenge is how do we
take that property and we have invested
a lot of our own money into it and make
it profitable and not lose money
um yeah so this try we'll see what
happens if we manage to succeed I can go
bigger and bigger until I achieve that
business model to be able to be the
whole operation in-house what's the cost
of like the budget for that first film
when you shot the three differences that
was ten thousand dollars for the day so
it wasn't it's not that that's not bad
it's not that bad yeah three full-on
videos camera a team of 15 people
collaborations you know why it's because
we did a lot of innovating we did a lot
of okay let's take a look at the way a
traditional set has been done
how do we save time on lighting how do
we save it on a sound in fact I ran I
single-handedly ran the entire sound
Department oh wow so you're you're a
good audio guy uh I'm not a guy
I know people are going to watch the
video now go Jesus sounds terrible it's
because I read it no I'm not an audio
guy but I do have that I do have the the
scrappiness of no matter what it is
let's get it done yeah I'll get it done
I don't know a thing about audio the
night before I was up till 3am sorting
the mics that I just rented that I had
no clue how to use and reading the
manual
um so yeah how do we create like 50k
worth of value was 10K that is a very
key part of the business model and then
on ginorma I learned a lot as well and
we used uh we use things that are never
seen in traditional Hollywood we're very
behind and I think in the last
three days we needed to shoot
a lot we missed you like 80 pages I need
to check if if that's the specific
number but we need to shoot way more
than was possible if you look at if you
ask any traditional set that's
ridiculous 80 pages in three days
um we ended up effectively tripling our
productivity by building and operating
three sets at the same time and we had
I'm not a director on the show but I'll
go direct the green screen set you know
you go direct this that person will take
care of that
um so with tactics like this and a
couple more uh we managed to get it done
and that's a very large part of the
business but I feel like in the future
I'll have a lot more to innovate so that
I can deliver your product that looks
like it costs 10 million dollars for
100k
I bet it can be done I already own the
cameras that shoot Oscar winners so it I
know it can be done it just has to you
know someone has to come and figure out
how wow so what's your team look like
now my team is very small uh
my team is very small I have two editors
that work with me all the time and um
most others on my team are like the
management level so they negotiate Deals
they procure opportunities things like
that and that's my team yeah I have I
hope people very small
um I do have that Spirit of YouTuber
I'll do everything myself you know I
don't know how to edit I'll figure it
out yeah I don't know how to write I'll
figure it out what percentage of humans
do you think are good-natured
all of them every single and that is a
that is a really dangerous statement uh
but I have
there there's this old Chinese proverb
which I really began to understand
recently and uh and it means a lot to me
and it's called
and it describes
I'm just laughing at all the way people
could like uh people could judge me
but it means
um all humans are born
kind
even though
the experiences of humans can be
different our nature is the same
uh there's a very very thousands of
years old Chinese proverb
um and it's kind of like this
this concept that
we are what the world has shaped us to
be
um and a lot of the times it's not
people's fault the way they are
when you know a world the world could
have put something on them and made them
into something that we receive as
negative
um and it has helped me to go a long way
to understand that is one thing uh I've
had a growth as a person like before I
obviously like with my experiences I
face bullies and there are many moments
where I where I would um hate people
but after understanding that proverb
it's it's like an acceptance It's like
yeah sure you might have caused me harm
but you are the way you are because of
every moment you have lived because of
where the word put you
um so I can't really blame you for what
you harmed me
you're you know a victim of your
surroundings too if it's bad
uh so yeah that is my answer to that
question so you don't think that there
could be someone out there though that's
born just naturally evil uh that's a
really good question because uh that
steps a line between belief and science
and uh I I kind of like I saw a little
bit towards science so the second you
ask that my brain goes to
because hormones chemicals chemicals yes
certain people are born obviously with
like different mental disorders
stability stuff like that yeah just
certain synapses not firing in their
brain yeah I'm sure that there are some
that probably can are somehow commingled
with human nature right yes that are
white differently to how we consider as
kind oh well when you put in that
perspective then it does make sense to
me that certain cubers or certain humans
can be born with a biology that is
different uh I accept that yeah I accept
that I I'm a firm believer that like 99
of the people that we consider evil are
like bad doers aren't actually like a
part of that population that are born
evil but they're just people like you
said that are subjects to their
surroundings or victims to their
surroundings right and that has kind of
crafted them into who they are yes um
but I do definitely think that there is
a statistic there that are probably just
naturally born oh I can see I know it's
a major yeah but I think it's a very
very very minute group of people right
and of the amount of people that we
ascribe the word evil to I think it's
like hardly even a statistic within that
gotcha yeah yes oh yeah then then I see
what you mean that that the the biology
of a person can be born with a
difference that we consider evil yeah I
can understand that I love the
perspective though the open-mindedness
perspective that's kind of an epiphany
I've been having over the past probably
at this point six months okay I'm like
trying to understand why people that I
just inherently disagree with yeah do
the things that they do yeah and I kind
of have come to the realization similar
to what you said that they're just a
product of whatever the environment that
they grew up in and I grew up in a
completely different environment and I'm
a product of that environment yeah and I
just have to understand that similar to
what Tom bilyu was saying
um you see life through a lens and the
longer you live your own life the more
obscured your lens gets and your
perspective of reality is more obviously
Twisted right what's your unique view
exactly and you just have to understand
that everybody has a lens yes that
understanding helps a lot it helps a lot
it dissolves the anger I used to have
you know yeah it dissolves the
negativity I used to have you know the
way that you can look a world very
negative the world very negatively
because things have happened to you and
because other people have harmed you
um but now with the understanding of oh
it's an understanding in general with
understanding
um it helps you be a better person where
you are it helps you make decisions that
are not
to give hate back to someone but to
improve yourself and to bring value to
the world
yeah so it's a very helpful thought
interesting question and very deep
I don't mind that what do you think is
the biggest threat to humanity wow there
were too many there are too many oh
just right off the top of my head uh
disease
um uh a pot like like weather and and
the Earth and there's there's just so
many things that could go wrong with our
environment you know uh from extremely
quick things like a meteor to to longer
things like resources running out or if
just if something just changed we longer
has sunlight we're in trouble if we no
longer if we lost water we're in trouble
there's so many things that go around
there
um I'm very fascinated by the whole AI
thing that is a very popular answer for
the end of humanity I don't know how it
would lead to the end of humanity but
like all the films all the films
basically go Terminator yeah yeah yeah
well think they're better than humans
and and human that's like everyone goes
there uh
I don't know if that'll ever be true
um AI what could I do that would
I can't understand the film perspective
right because it kind of makes sense now
if if we craft AI to be the best living
life form it can be and it goes oh
humans are are drawing and dragging us
back then yeah fair I can see that
but I wonder how else AI can affect
human can affect humans that that might
be the answer I've had this I've had
this mental thought for a while I'm
intrigued by the concept of
evolving into
a being that is like an AI that is
Immortal that is not a a
that is not in this Mortal coil but can
live as long as we want and can improve
ourselves by adding you know
capabilities
um and and the thought is like how do we
integrate with machine
um and I and the thought was kind of
like yeah if you copy your brain sure
you have another version of you that's
running around and yeah you can pretty
much say it is you but your fleshy brain
is still gonna die yeah like irregular
like almost like hey what about if you
replace it one by one because then
you're in The Grandfather's ship Paradox
right each year you just swap out one
percent of your brain for a machine and
the next year one percent next year one
percent so you never really stop being
you and you never really start being the
machine it's always you then you wonder
what defines Humanity at that point yeah
that's gonna be a big question 50 50
the great answer is Right smack in the
middle fifty percent romance that's it
that's it if you're more if you're 51
one way or another then it's like you
did a passport I'm Still Human yeah
exactly 51 still counts yeah yeah that's
crazy I I like to think that um
it can be what we want it to be we have
the power of the choice we can decide to
to go back into what Humanity always was
or we can decide to change Humanity into
a new thing I I'd like to I like to
believe that's our decision
yeah fascinating thoughts very
fascinating thoughts is there anything
else you want to discuss I wanted to
tell all friends stories of going back
in Sherlock please do they will be
whatever you want to revisit yeah oh
yeah oh yeah I did I told a lot of
stories and I think they would be the
the clips that go viral you know you
could always roast me as the uh Asian
Dad
that was good I actually I'm actually
very impressed by by your frugalism
because uh I oh this is a weird
perspective now
um growing up
as a kid even I felt this that that you
would look down on frugalism right
because you have this whole nation of
people who's not used to having money
suddenly has money and now there is the
insecurity of I don't want to be seen as
poor and that insecurity kind of
manifests into uh if someone is Frugal
you might look down upon them like I had
this personal experience that very very
very much regret now but back then you
know I was a product of my my society as
well where we go to my my grandma and I
uh you know wait actually tell that
story
so I remember uh I was young I was like
five I was like four or five with my mom
in China at the time
um and my mom all of a sudden this was
like right when things blew up my mom
said uh hey we're gonna take uh we're
gonna take you guys to a
five-star experience yeah and me and my
friend it was like a playdate me me a
friend
and both are blobs uh and she was like
guys we're gonna go to this like amazing
this we're going above the budget this
time okay and that we were hyper hyped
and we went to this restaurant
um that was so new and we were told like
this is uh this is the international
Exotics is the American stuff right this
is from America and to us I was like oh
my God that's amazing America is great
because we really look up to America you
know and so like wow we're experiencing
what is uh what things are like there
and I remember I had like the best meal
I had I enjoyed it so much and I never
eat any food like it it wasn't rice it
wasn't you know the things I'm used to
eating uh and then there was a
playground and we'd like if we went on a
swing I don't know if I've ever been on
a swing before uh and
we had a blast of a time and it was a
McDonald's
[Music]
but you know what if you haven't had it
before it's delicious I think it was the
first McDonald's
and I remember it so fondly so fondly
I'm surprised it wasn't an off brand
yeah
and I always kept that experience then
KFC came in oh my God it was the best
thing ever we would go hang out there if
you weren't even eating even if likes
the hangout spot yeah even like you had
lunch but you still go you get like an
ice cream sundae you were the cool kid
you know it was the spot
um and then I remembered this oh it was
such a visceral experience my first time
coming to the United States I came into
Penn Station New York and I saw the KFC
sign and I was like oh there's my place
let's go I was so disappointed bro no it
was so just it was dirty the floor was
greasy there was one person running the
shop and it was stained and rusted and
the food didn't taste nearly as good as
I remembered so that was a massive
paradigm shift I had always had this
idea wow and then Penn Station crush it
for me sorry man
you've gotten it since then right
I got a bit it's not any KFC or
McDonald's I've had in the United States
is nothing like the experience I had in
China KFC's also gotten all downhill to
be completely honest I ate it a little
bit as a kid and it was really good but
I've gone recently it's just it's
wonderful what's going on bring it back
man in fact I'll go to bed in China just
to have kids it's so great over there
that would be actually really
interesting comparing the difference of
like it's staggering bro and KFC there
at KFC here it's awesome KFC yeah that
would be interesting
video yeah people would be very curious
to see what the differences are yeah
yeah they some of them are so good
though some are so good you might as
well go to that rather than the real one
was there like elitism when it came to
like being a consumer of a real KFC
versus a fake one like if you go to
school a fake lunch not fake no no okay
it's like a replica case yeah like a
replica KFC because you were saying
there's a lot of off Brands so when you
show up to school like does someone oh
you have a McDonald's burger
oh you have you have Illinois Fried
Chicken Kentucky Fried Chicken
from my experience everybody loved the
off Brands okay it might we might have
even loved it more than the actual thing
okay yeah we loved it there was an
intimacy there you know KFC felt
corporate which isn't a bad thing we
still enjoy the experience but the
offering KFC was run by like a mom and
pop you know they were in the back front
of the chicken and they came to the
front to do your order
um so everyone loved it I definitely
loved that that's cool yeah the stories
from China oh geez makes me happy he's
telling these stories how hard would it
be to visit revisit China would it be
easy for you now is it I believe so I
believe so because I am going back uh to
see family this year later this year
uh I haven't been in a while actually I
I do feel Chinese culture moves really
fast I've noticed this uh ever since I
came to the West
like
I'll leave for two years and then I'll
get in contact with my Chinese friends
and all of a sudden I don't know what
people are saying there's new
catchphrase coming up there's new
Expressions uh the new hot thing has
changed you know people wear different
clothes now people play different games
now so I have felt like you can lose
touch very fast
um and now I do I do feel when I go back
to I don't know any of the popular
movies I don't know any of the you know
popular activities people do that's
there's a weird like feeling like I'm an
outsider now but oh well I'm an
immigrant so I guess that that kind of
that's fair as a kid growing up in China
how is the general quality of life there
because it oh you said they're all the
pressures that the kids see I also heard
I don't know what it was from but I
think it was like a clip from a podcast
where they were saying that
I don't want to say the word but like
when you uh end your own life those
rates are extremely high I don't know if
the statistic is true uh in certain
situations where the child is facing a
ton of pressure from their parents to
perform well and they feel inadequate
was the General quality of life and
consensus amongst kids in China good
positive
yes yes because when I think back of my
life and
I don't know I guess you could call me
an average kid until I until I am
magrudu
my memories are good uh I could also be
lucky in the way that the academics came
easy to me like math and all that came
easy to me
um but I do remember things were very
good I remember
initiation was the thing and that's a
very interesting concept I've I've uh
kind of realized talking to
other peoples of international Origins
um and it's kind of like the glass half
empty glass half full question
it's there is a definitive answer it is
the journey from where you came so like
the definitive answer of that question
is if you have a full glass and you pour
half it out it is now half empty if you
have an empty glass you fill half it is
now half full so how that relates to us
is
for my Grandpa Grandma my mom and dad
and me to come from a a time where it
was difficult to eat
to a time where everyone had clothes and
were like we got school to go to and we
got books to read and we can eat
whenever you want to me being born uh
and my life was absolute luxury I could
eat meat every day like this is
us people understate this but it was a
big deal it was a very very big deal
that I can eat meat every day and the
fact that I got some Mass on me I'm not
skinny
um that was a great thing that we very
very much appreciated so my memory
growing up is my grandma would sing
songs in the kitchen about the
government because you know she had food
and all of this great things that um
like
people in a better situation may take
for granted and so I think that answers
that question it's because we have seen
such great growth and such great
progress that we really appreciate
everything we had and we're happy I was
happy anyway yeah of course my
experience doesn't uh doesn't speak for
everyone's experience but it's an
interesting analogy yeah that's where
you come from yeah
cool I like it well thank you so much
appreciate it I very much enjoyed this
yeah thank you thank you oh man I can't
believe I'm gonna be on your channel
yes we did it all right man thank you no
emotions thank you guys so much for
watching if you've made it this far feel
free to add me on Instagram also check
out of course all of his links are going
to be posted
public.com
when you make a deposit
see cheers oh man I love that